je veux pas être ça pourquoi je suis
comme ça et trans ce sont les premières
images du documentaire tiga signé doris
buttignol nous sommes en mai 2015
vincent gabriel est né dans le corps
d'une femme et tente par tous les moyens
d'aplatir sa poitrine
c'est le début d'une longue transition
c'est vraiment tous les jours je vais
travailler ici dix ans que le caporal
vincent gabriel la marée dans les forces
armées canadiennes y les chauffeurs
répartiteurs
mais à son arrivée en 2008 elle
s'appelait virginie la mare surnommé ti
gars père devenu une de ses premières
missions l'amène à conduire un camion
contenant vingt mille litres de diesel
sur les routes sinueuses de
l'afghanistan un défi que le caporal
relève avec succès mais son plus grand
défi se situe au niveau personnel depuis
l'âge de 3 ans il sait qu'il n'est pas
né dans le bon corps et ce n'est que
récemment qu'il entame une transition de
genre
le documentaire relate chaque étape de
la transition
d'abord l'injection de testostérone
soleil discret de la caméra une
injection qui devra se faire chaque
semaine puis l'ablation des seins
cette mastectomie tant attendu et puis
l'hystérectomie se débarrasser de cet
utérus de trop c'est plus tough ont rêvé
qu'elle a un master
non
le
chaque étape se vit comme une délivrance
pour vincent une affaire personnelle
mais aussi familial où sa mère sa
grand-mère le soutiennent de près mais
il ya aussi l'autre famille l'armée
canadienne qui l'encadrent dans cette
transition
une situation exceptionnelle où famille
employeurs l'appui dans ses démarches
la discrimination c'est à dire 1 0 des
belles initiatives comme diversité plus
au sein de la deuxième division qui
rêvait comité consultatif pour donner
des recommandations à chaîne de
commandement et à sensibiliser aussi les
membres de la deuxième division sur les
différents enjeux de de diversité des
fois les obstacles qui peuvent encore se
poser dans l'armée on voit ça comme un
milieu très conservateur j'ai jamais
sentie ce côté là j'ai vu constamment
une amélioration a essayé de se
développer à suivre ils font le monde
comment que ça se passe pour la
réalisatrice ce film porte surtout sur
une aventure humaine
moi c'est pas un film médicale vincent
est quelqu'un qui a était jusqu'au bout
du questionnement de son identité
ressenti qui n'étaient pas en accord
avec son corps et que sais je pense que
c'est une question qui est universel à
32 ans vincent gabriel se sent libérée
d'un lourd fardeau
virginie m'a amené à être vincent
gabriel la personne que je suis
aujourd'hui mais ça moi même j'ai plus
l'impression de jouer un rôle mais
interaction avec les gens complètement
changé avant j'avais tendance un petit
peu plus à m'isoler en fureur en recul
j'ai des projets d'avenir ce que je
faisais pas à 20 ces projets devenir
technicien médical mais aussi partager
son histoire
pour lui c'est une renaissance un
nouveau départ dans la vie
ici à zaboul rigueur guise radio canada
saint jean sur richelieu